[Music]
[Laughter]
barber bionic ott
in the type
[Music]
but the processes of insertion
[Laughter]
[Laughter
] generally in fact of far east
mourinho
if there will be for made in facebook he
writes
the widget people and 6
in bitter moments
the knots
instead we sense hope it is right that
it
then went into gangster orbit sorry
for the buses
excuse me
[Music]
spin off
excuse
many whistles little dirty unmasked
weight
this is out our schemes
in the summer times on the journalists
out
[Laughter]
bad the rainbow files
experiential francis claudio crisis
are dirty I'm like me regime
now that of the people are there are we
the kings explained welfare socio-
economic standpoint mi6 battisti
marine scenarios
yes no
who can stay
white plains of about 6 minutes without
insertions has
[Laughter]
valentino bosco di assignments
is a company in crisis
[Music]